Hi everyone, it's Jerry. I have an excellent opening trap to share with you. This was played
at the 1958-59 U.S. Championship. On the white end Bobby Fischer playing against Samuel Reshevsky.
This is a 15-year-old Fischer. He won this event, became champ, beat out second place
Samuel Reshevsky by one point. This was Reshevsky's only loss of the event. So you might as well
say this game here won Fischer the championship. We have an Accelerated Dragon. Fischer's reply,
bishop b3. Instead, if white castles, this would allow the center fork trick. Capture
on e4, and then d5. This is black's way to get the piece back. This helps us understand
why the bishop takes a step back. No more center fork trick. The reply now by Reshevsky,
knight a5. Important moment in the game. I wonder if you can spot Fischer's continuation. Feel
free to pause the video and give this one some time. I will be devoting some time to
it. Okay. Before I share the continuation, what I'd like to do is share how I think an
experienced player may see this position. What squares light up in the mind of an experienced
player, and why those squares light up. First of all, we have b3 and c4. These are squares
that the knight now controls from a5. Additionally, there are the squares d4 and e5. These are squares
the knight no longer controls. This helps draw our attention to what new possibilities are
available to white. Is there a way to take advantage of the weakness of the last move?
White's pawn can advance in the center and challenge the king knight. Where would it go?
If it goes to the edge, it can be trapped with g4. What other options does it have? It would have
to go in reverse. And when it goes in reverse, we would have the other center squares lighting up.
It no longer controls d5 and e4. Anything else? Yes. Another key note. When the knight is on e8,
there's a disconnect between the major pieces, and the black queen is all of a sudden unprotected.
The continuation in this game, e5. The best continuation for black at this stage. Not a
pleasant one, but this is considered best. To take the bishop and allow this imbalance. The
two minor pieces versus the rook. This knight will be tracked soon enough. In this game though,
the knight immediately goes back. And now we have this winning tactical shot. Bishop takes f7.
This takes full advantage of the unprotected queen. What are black's options? Take with the
rook, take with the king, or run in the corner. Regardless of what move is played, the continuation
will be the same. And that is knight e6. The queen is dead. No safe squares. These two are
covered. This one is covered. And what are black's options? If you take with the king,
it's going to lead to mate. What does that mate look like? Queen d5. G4 with check. Gladly pitch
a pawn to open a file for another piece. And if you go here, that's mate. And if the king goes to
any of the h file squares, you could play queen g2, and soon enough it's going to be mate on one
of these squares in just a couple moves at most. Alright. The move played in this game, pawn
takes knight. It's already over. Queen is a goner. A winning tactical shot. I'll just be playing through
the rest of this game and making some light notes in general. I want to trade down up the material.
It's a queen versus two minor pieces. And we're going to see that whenever black tries to get in
a coordinated position, it's broken down. So improving the knight. Improving the knight further.
e6 is in the crosshairs. Some control of the knight. Activate the rook. Get some trades in here.
Pinpoint the weaknesses. e6 under fire. It's defended, but now the rook is harassed a bunch
of times. And where do you go at this stage? If you go to one of these two, knight g5 would target
the rook and h7. So the e pawn, in short, is now a goner with check. And from here, we get some
trades in with the fork. No more dark square bishop. This is a stable piece, but not for long.
In comes the b pawn. The knight will soon have to find a new square. a6 is not stopping b5 because
another unprotected piece in the position. b5 would still hit. Rooks are now connected.
Knight's driven back. Reposition the rook, trying to get to the prized seventh rank. a6, b6,
bishop e4, and bishop c6. Second time now, we have this piece, a minor piece, I should say,
on c6. It's eliminated. Give back some material. Break things down. And with that, there's now a
passer that immediately advances. In the game, the rook goes to b8. If you try to attack the pawn
while still defending a6, there's the tactical shot, queen takes rook. And then you promote,
get a new queen with check, and take some more material. Alright, rook b8, queen takes a.
Black ends up tracking down the b pawn, but this means there's going to be more exchanges.
Queen a8, final move of the game, black resigns. There's no hope here. What do you try?
Check, king h2. You have to find a safe square for your knight. Maybe you go here. The plan,
push your a pawn. Best case scenario for black, maybe you're able to sacrifice the knight for
the a pawn. But in that position, yeah, the rook is going to be no match for the queen.
So what'd you think of this one? Did you find Fischer's winning tactical sequence out of the
opening? The idea I had with sharing this game, this opening trap, is to draw your attention to
what pieces do and no longer do after a move. It's not about this one trap. It's not like,
hey, if you're ever in this exact position sometime, do this. No. I think focusing on
the key differences in the position as a piece moves from one square to the next
is an excellent blueprint for finding best continuations.
Anyhow, feel free, as usual, to leave any feedback to this video in the comments section below.
I hope you enjoyed it. And maybe took a thing or two away. That's all for now. Take care. Bye.